MONKEYPOX IS SPREADING RAPIDLY
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES RIGHT
NOW.
THE CDC IS NOW REPORTING MORE
THAN 1800 CONFIRMED CASES AS OF
FRIDAY.
THERE WERE 866 CASES REPORTED AS
OF LAST MONDAY, WHICH IS A 110%
INCREASE IN FIVE DAYS OF
CONFIRMED REPORTED CASES.
NOW, THE FORMER FDA CASE DR.
SCOTT GOTTLIEB IS SAYING IT MAY
BE TOO LATE TO CONTAIN THE
OUTBREAK.
>> I THINK THE WINDOW FOR
GETTING CONTROL OF THIS AND
CONTAINING IT PROBABLY HAS
CLOSED.
IF IT HASN'T CLOSED, IT'S
STARTING TO CLOSE.
WE COULD HAVE GOTTEN CONTROL OF
THIS IF WE HAD BEEN MORE
AGGRESSIVE.
WE MADE A LOT OF THE SAME
MISTAKES WITH COVID WITH THIS,
HAVING A NARROW CASE DEFINITION,
NOT ENOUGH DEPLOYING OF A
VACC
VACCINE.
>> JOINING US NOW IS DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI, CHIEF MEDICAL ADVISER TO
JOE BIDEN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT'S
SCOTT GOTTLIEB HAD TO SAY RIGHT
THERE ABOUT THE RESPONSE SO FAR?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THE
WINDOW HAS CLOSED.
THERE'S A LOT THAT HAS BEEN DONE
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO AND
ACCELERATE.
BOTH FROM THE STANDPOINT OF THE
TESTING THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE.
OF COURSE, IN THE BEGINNING,
THERE WERE ONLY THE CDC TESTS
THAT WERE AVAILABLE.
RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE RAPIDLY
COMMERCIALIZED, SO THAT WE HAVE
FIVE SOURCES NOW, AT LEAST, AND
MAYBE MORE.
WE HAVE LAB CORP, QUEST, MAYO
CLINIC, AS WELL AS THE NETWORK
FROM THE CDC.
SO UP TO MAYBE 10,000 CASES --
EXCUSE ME, 10,000 TESTS PER DAY
IS NOW GOING TO BE FIVE, SIX,
SEVEN TIMES THAT.
THE ISSUE WITH VACCINES IS
IMPORTANT.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN GOOD TO HAVE
A LOT MORE VACCINES AVAILABLE
EARLY ON.
BUT RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE
ACCELERATED THAT EXTENSIVELY.
WE HAD ABOUT 130,000 DOSES AT
FIRST.
ANOTHER 154,000.
BY THE END OF JULY, THERE SHOULD
BE ANOTHER 700,000 PLUS.
SO ONE OF THE DIFFERENCES OF
THIS TYPE OF AN OUTBREAK FROM
OTHERS THAT WE HAD, A, WE KNOW
THE AGENT.
IT 17B8ISN'T LIKE A MYSTERY WITV
DECADES AGO.
TWO, WE HAVE A VACCINE THAT WILL
BECOME MORE WIDELY AVAILABLE.
WE HAVE DIAGNOSTICS, AND WE HAVE
THERAPY.
THERAPY THAT WE ORIGINALLY
DEVELOPED YEARS AGO AGAINST
SMALLPOX WHEN WE WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT A SITUATION OF BIOTERROR.
COULD WE HAVE DONE BETTER?
ALWAYS.
YOU NEVER SAY WE DID PERFECTLY.
BUT LOOKING FORWARD, WITH MORE
VACCINES BEING AVAILABLE WITH
THERAPY BEING AVAILABLE, AND
THERE IS A LOT OF RED TAPE
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT, WHICH THE
FDA AND CDC AND OTHERS ARE
TRYING TO CUT DOWN DRAMATICALLY
ON THE PAPERWORK ASSOCIATED WITH
GETTING DRUGS TO PEOPLE WHO
WOULD BE BENEFITING FROM
THERAPY.
SO, AGAIN, RESPONSE HASN'T BEEN
PERFECT, BUT IT'S GETTING BETTER
AND BETTER.
>> THE CDC DIRECTOR ON FRIDAY
TALKED ABOUT HOW MONKEYPOX CAN
BE SPREAD.
SHE MENTIONED SKIN-TO-SKIN
CONTACT LIKE KISSING, BUT
TOUCHING OBJECTS LIKE SHEETS OR
TOWELS.
HAVE YOU SEEN CASES CONTRACTED
THIS WAY, NOT THROUGH INTIMATE
CONTACT, WHICH HAS BEEN
PRIMARILY HOW IT'S BEEN
DESCRIBED.
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK WE CAN
SPEAK AT THIS POINT, KATE, TO
INDIVIDUAL CASES THAT YOU SAY
ABSOLUTELY WAS -- WERE THEY
INANIMATE OBJECTS, CLOTHES, BUT
WE KNOW WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
SPREAD OF A VERY SIMILAR VIRUS,
SMALLPOX, WHEN YOU GET THE
POSCULES, WHEN THE MATERIAL FROM
THOSE CAN GET INTO CLOTHING OR
INANIMATE OBJECTS, IT'S QUITE
UNDERSTANDABLE HOW, OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME, CONTACT WITH
THAT COULD SPREAD.
IT SO THERE MAY NOT BE A DEFINED
CASE THAT YOU CAN POINT TO, BUT
CONCEPTUALLY, WE KNOW THAT HAS
OCCURRED FOR DECADES AND DECADES
WITH SMALLPOX.
SO IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT IT
COULD ALSO OCCUR WITH THIS
VIRUS.
>> BECAUSE THAT IS IMPORTANT IN
KNOWING -- AS IT WAS WITH COVID,
HOW CLOSE WOULD WE BE?
HOW FAR DO YOUR AEROSOLS SPREAD?
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR LEVEL OF RISK.
>> EXACTLY.
BUT I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP IN
THAT CONTEXT, KATE.
WE KNOW NOW FROM CLEAR
EPIDEMIOLOGICAL INFORMATION THAT
IT IS CLOSE PERSON-TO-PERSON,
SKIN-TO-SKIN CONTACT.
OBVIOUSLY, FROM A DEMOGRAPHIC
STANDPOINT, IT'S HEAVILY
WEIGHTED TO MEN WHO HAVE SEX
WITH MEN.
NOW, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT, DOES
THAT MEAN IT'S ONLY A GAY MAN'S
DISEASE?
NO, NOT THE CASE.
BUT UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
CERTAIN TYPES OF BEHAVIOR, THAT
CAN BE SPREAD.
WHICH IS THE REASON WHY YOU DO
NOT WANT TO STIGMATIZE UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES, PEOPLE WHO ARE
GETTING AFFLICTED WITH A
PARTICULAR INFECTIOUS DISEASE,
YOU HAVE TO LET THE COMMUNITY
KNOW OF THE DANGER, AND YOU HAVE
TO LET THE PHYSICIANS WHO CARE
FOR THESE PEOPLE BE AWARE OF IT,
SO THAT THEY DON'T MISS THE
DIAGNOSIS.
BUT CLEARLY, THE MODALITY OF
SPREAD IS CLOSE SKIN-TO-SKIN
CONTACT.
>> DR. FAUCI, JUST BEFORE AIR, I
SAW NEWS THAT YOU ARE ANNOUNCING
YOUR RETIREMENT PLANS NOW.
WHAT ARE THE PLANS, AND WHY NOW?
>> WELL, THAT IS NOT NEWS.
THAT'S INCORRECT.
IF ONE READS THE -- I UNDERSTAND
THE --
>> I DO NOT SPREAD THIS
INFORMATION.
I SAW YOU WERE SPEAKING ABOUT
YOUR PLANS FOR RETIREMENT.
>> I KNOW YOU DON'T.
KATE, I KNOW YOU DON'T.
I HAVE KNOWN YOU A LONG TIME.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED IS I GAVE AN
INTERVIEW WITH REPORTER, AND
THEY SAID, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO STEP DOWN
SOMETIME, YOU CAN'T BE IN THIS
JOB FOREVER.
I SAID YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
I CAN'T BE IN THIS JOB FOREVER,
AND I DON'T ANTICIPATE I WILL BE
IN THIS JOB BEFORE THE -- AT THE
END OF THE FIRST TERM OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN, WHICH IS
JANUARY 2025.
SOMEHOW, THAT GOT INTERPRETED
THAT IT'S ANNOUNCING MY
RETIREMENT.
I JUST SAID THAT IT IS EXTREMELY
UNLIKELY.
IN FACT, FOR SURE THAT I'M NOT
GOING TO BE HERE BEYOND JANUARY
2025.
SO SOMETIME BETWEEN NOW, KATE,
AND JANUARY 2025, YOU CAN
GUARANTEE I'LL STEP DOWN.
>> THIS IS HOW MUCH TIME PEOPLE
NEED TO PREPARE FOR A SEA CHANGE
LIKE THAT.
I SAY THAT ONLY HALF WITH HUMOR,
BECAUSE AFTER -- I MEAN, ALMOST
FIVE DECADES IN FEDERAL SERVICE,
I MEAN, THAT IS -- IT IS A MAJOR
ANNOUNCEMENT.
WHAT IMPACT --
>> 54 YEARS.
>> WHAT IMPACTS YOUR DECISION?
DID THE PANDEMIC, THE SPOTLIGHT
IT PUT ON YOU, YOU HAVE BEEN
CANDID ABOUT THAT.
DID THAT IMPACT YOUR THOUGHT
PROCESS ON RETIREMENT?
>> NO.
NO, NOT AT ALL, KATE.
FIRST OF ALL, I HAVE ESTABLISHED
AS 38 YEARS AS DIRECTOR OF
NIADA.
I THINK THE BEST PROGRAM IN THE
WORLD WHEN IT COMES TO
INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
EVERYBODY IS IN A POSITION OF
ANY INFLUENCE IN MY INSTITUTE, I
HAND PICK.
SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR ALMOST FOUR
DECADES.
SO WE HAVE A GOOD SYSTEM IN
PLACE.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU CAN'T GO ON
FOREVER.
I DO WANT TO DO OTHER THINGS IN
MY CAREER.
EVEN THOUGH I'M AT A RATHER
ADVANCED AGE, I HAVE THE ENERGY
AND THE PASSION TO CONTINUE TO
WANT TO PURSUE OTHER ASPECTS OF
MY PROFESSIONAL CAREER.
AND I'M GOING TO DO THAT
SOMETIME.
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE WHEN, BUT I
DON'T SEE MYSELF BEING IN THIS
JOB TO THE POINT WHERE I CAN'T
DO ANYTHING ELSE AFTER THAT.
SO THAT'S THE REASON.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
PRESSURES, NOTHING TO DO WITH
ALL THE OTHER NONSENSE THAT YOU
HEAR ABOUT,
THAT HAS NO INFLUENCE ON ME.
>> WELL, I ANTICIPATE I'LL HAVE
MANY MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO BUG
YOU IN THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS
ABOUT MORE OF YOUR RETIREMENT
PLANS AND YOUR NEXT CHAPTER.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU, DR. FAUCI.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.